hey youtubers is Charlie since so many
new characters have been announced on
arrow in the flash I wanted to do a
video series for some of the bigger ones
so this is gonna be all about Captain
Cold
why is he a big deal well he's one of
the most famous flash villains and he's
being played by Wentworth Miller from
Prison Break I can already hear the iron
Heights prison break memes so I'm gonna
start with his origin story in the
comics and then I'll talk about how the
show might use the character if you're
finding me for the first time I do flash
and arrow videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a really exciting season and real
quick heads up - if you have seen the
first episode please use spoiler tags in
the comments because most people still
have not seen it yet so captain colds
real name is Leonard snart so whenever
the show introduces him that's who we're
gonna see first eventually over time
he's gonna turn into Captain Cold
probably in that same episode he debuts
in they're not waiting before giving us
those big super villains I know you guys
are really happy about that less waiting
means more smashing time so they've
changed his origin story in the comics a
couple times but here's the original one
his first appearance was in 1957 he was
created by carmine infantino he's the
same person that created the flash so no
surprise that he created one of the
Flash's best villains - originally the
character would pull regular heists
trying to steal money using cold guns to
freeze things mostly to get women to
like him remember this is a long time
ago this is like in the 1950s eventually
he learned about a really big score so
he teamed up with some other super
villains that included his sister golden
glider the trickster and heatwave
they eventually were thwarted by Barry
Allen who had teamed up with Jay Garrick
who had come out of retirement that was
basically the beginning of the Rogues a
group of flash villains that banded
together just because they weren't
strong enough on their own to fight the
flash they're like the Bad News Bears of
villain teams think of the crime
syndicate is like the Yankees World
Series champs of evil the Rogues are
usually the guys that get their asses
handed to them every week so most of the
time in the comics they were used for
comedy so eventually in the comics his
backstory was changed a little bit
especially whenever geoff johns took
over the flash they made his sister a
much bigger part of his backstory like
he was a criminal because he needed
money to take care of his sister just to
make the character more sympathetic he's
not a villain because he's straight-up
evil he's a villain of circumstance
which is probably how the TV show is
gonna treat him there was a period in
the comics whenever he tried to reform
he
made this company called golden
recoveries with his sister golden
Collider but like a lot of reformed
villains it didn't stick and he ended up
killing his former prison inmate named
Brad Brickley the case became this big
unsolved mystery with the central city
police department it was used to test
new cadets eventually Bart Allen solved
it but the show isn't doing Bart Allen
at least right now right now on the show
the big unsolved mystery is Barry's
mother's murder before Geoff Johns and
DC Comics did their hold new 52 reboot
captain cold and the Rogues even went on
to kill Bart Allen during the whole
flashpoint storyline he actually tried
to live a normal life as citizen cold
masquerading as a hero of the city just
trying to hide his past crimes he even
had this weird relationship with iris
West it was like a godfather situation
where he tried to go legit and then the
other rogues got pissed they did up
kidnapping his sister and revenge
murdering her so he went on to kill them
and then iris West turned on him so the
general theme is is that whenever
Captain Cold tries to go legit things do
not go well
like he's not allowed to be legit in the
DC Universe after the new 52 reboot all
the Rogues including Captain Cold were
given real-life superpowers as part of a
freak accident with STAR Labs so
essentially now he doesn't need his cold
guns to free stuff anymore and obviously
that's the way the show is gonna do it -
in case you never read any of the old
flash comics or the new ones
whenever DC did the big new 52 reboot
they basically wiped all the old stuff
from continuity so whenever you meet the
new Captain Cold you're essentially
meeting him for the first time so
whenever we see him on the show we're
probably gonna be seeing the new 52
version although Geoff Johns and the
other writers are really good about
including Easter eggs from the classic
comics if you want to read some really
cool quote-unquote Captain Cold stories
you should just check out Geoff Johns
flash omnibus there are three different
volumes and they're all awesome he
actually goes to a lot of comic book
conventions and he's really nice to his
fans so you might be able to get Jeff
Johnson to sign one of those if you give
it to him on the show Wentworth Miller
is going to debut as Leonard snart in
Episode four that's also the same
episode felicity is guest starring in
from arrow the title of the episode is
Oracle so as much as it's an
introduction to Captain Cold I think
it's going to be more of a Felicity
episode I know comic book fans went a
little nuts when they heard that title -
Oracle is the name Barbara Gordon takes
whenever she forms the birds of prey
group arrow did a birds-of-prey episode
last year and they're going to do it
again this year and yes Felicity will be
the Oracle of the team with hunters and
Black Canary
I know Black Canary technically left at
the end of last season but she's back in
season three for three episodes if she
leaves the show before they do a
birds-of-prey episode they might just
substitute katana for Black Canary in
the group the Captain Cold episode on
the flash that's not going to be a
birds-of-prey story or anything but it
will explain how the show's gonna treat
his character because the particle
accelerator explosion isn't the
MacGuffin you know the thing that
creates all the metahumans it's likely
that Wentworth Miller will be a normal
person in a bad situation
who just figures superpowers are the
answers to all his problems I'm hoping
that he's in a situation where he's
trying to help his sister and then
Shazam he just gets powers and things go
horribly horribly wrong like he has a
really bad run with a flash there has to
be a reason for Captain Cold to hate him
to hate Barry Allen a reason for him to
form the Rogues on the show nobody knows
the flash exists like he's just debuting
now so they'll have to have that first
run-in and Barry's gonna have to do
something that will make Wentworth
Miller hate him think of it as like the
Batman problem Batman is a force of
nature in Gotham he's all about justice
but because he's so aggressive he causes
a lot of collateral damage and forces
criminals to up their game thus super
weirdos start crawling out of the
woodwork so he basically creates as many
villains as he puts away in Arkham the
same is gonna be true for Barry Allen on
the flash for every road that he puts
away in iron Heights two more are gonna
rise up in their place oh wait that's
the wrong show hail Hydra just to
clarify iron Heights is like the Flash's
version of Arkham and think about
Wentworth Miller Prison Break in this
meta kind of way the first half of the
season is gonna be very faithful to the
comics so they're gonna be doing a freak
of the week model Barry's gonna be
arresting a lot of different people
eventually they'll all probably try to
band together and do a prison break so
it's totally possible that Wentworth
Miller could already be in prison when
we see him for the first time and then
the particle accelerator explosion gives
him powers which he then uses to break
out Wentworth Miller is a really
specific kind of actor though I feel
like they cast him because they wanted a
sympathetic villain which points back to
Captain colds sister either way it's
gonna be awesome
so because the flash is debuting October
7th that fourth episode that Captain
Cold episode is gonna be on October 28th
so think of it as like a Halloween
episode felicity Halloween episode
crossover it's gonna be so much fun
because Wentworth Miller is such a big
actor and Captain Cold is such a big
villain it feels like the show is gonna
use him as a medium bad this season as
like a brother blood type character
think of him as like the Darth Vader
there's always the Emperor waiting in
the distance which on the flash is gonna
be the reverse-flash or professor zoom
however you want to think about it but
before he reveals himself we got to get
a whole lot of rogues now to name the
winner of my Comic Con giveaway
congratulations to clock stomper you win
a flash from Co pop figure I'm gonna be
reaching out to your channel for details
but congratulations since I'm doing a
flash villains video series the next
video I'm going to do is going to be for
killer frost since that's the character
that danielle Panabaker is playing on
the show be sure to subscribe to get
that I'm also working on the same type
of video series for era so my video
tonight is gonna be an arrow video but
right now click here to get my review of
the pilot episode of the flash and click
here to learn all about Robby Mills
firestorm character thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you